Hi I'm Steve the founder of link with
this method I learned 10 languages ​​on
link we don't teach languages ​​you have to
learn it on your own with a little
help obviously let's say you want to
learn Spanish you will start with a
lesson from the Spanish library
you will come across words  that you don't know
highlighted in blue if you hover over it with the
mouse you will see three suggestions for that
word Select one or click on
suggest to add another
excellent one you have just created a link the
blue word has become yellow and will appear
in yellow in all future texts for
learn any language You have to create
lots and lots of links Not only for
unknown words but also for those you
are not sure about your links will
never be too many review your
links using the I Close test cards or
our iPhone application and remember
to review the yellow links in each
lesson download the audio files to your
MP3 player and listen to them many times
listen to the key element Listen
while you go to work do gymnastics or
do the dishes every day this
process of reading and listening will help you
to speak the language fluently When
you're done move on to a new lesson it's
that simple if you have any questions ask for
help in the forum soon you'll want to
send written texts and participate in
conversations with the tutors he'll speak
Spanish In no time at all Good
luck